[Música]
bienvenidos y bienvenidas al espacio de
cultura de france 24 comenzamos este
programa con uno de los estrenos de cine
más esperados de este año el nombre del
norte la tercera película del director
estadounidense robert hersh de hamlet el
rey león 2 en las de cuentos nos han
familiarizado con la historia clásica
del hijo de un rey que quiere vengar a
su padre asesinado así que no es por su
trama que esta epopeya vikinga se
destaca sino por su fotografía inmersiva
y por su atmósfera brutal donde los
dioses y los monstruos de la cultura
nórdica se mezclan con las emociones
humanas más básicas el deseo la rabia el
amor y el dolor
otra obra sobre el dolor y cómo
transformar los seres humanos los
secretos de doblador es la tercera
entrega de la saga los animales
fantásticos y después de una película
anterior bastante decepcionante esta
última película eleva el nivel y hace
honor a los personajes y el universo
mágico de harry potter de que es
precuela el fabuloso más mikkelsen se
puso el traje de gran villano mago para
sustituir a johnny depp y con un uso más
fino y elegante de los efectos
especiales que alternan con algunos
momentos bastante divertidos y ligeros
los secretos de doble door ofrece un
espectáculo perfecto para las pantallas
de cine veamos el tráiler
nos tenéis
[Música]
me quedé encerrado
personas de gustarle
[Música]
magia de los animales fantásticos a la
emoción de las celebraciones que
compensan este mes de abril en américa
latina empezando por colombia celebrando
el cumpleaños del pintor y escultor
fernando botero es uno de los artistas
vivos más importantes del arte
contemporáneo mundial y cumplió 90 años
el 19 de abril la ciudad de medellín
donde nació le rindió homenaje tras un
concierto y una exposición su estilo
característico conocido como potter ismo
presenta figuras y personajes enormes y
exagerados y sus obras se encuentran en
lugares famosos de todo el mundo como
parque avenue en nueva york' y los
campos elíseos en parís
en abril américa latina celebra también
la vuelta de sus ferias internacionales
del libro después de dos años de
pandemia cuba colombia y argentina abren
el baile de estos encuentros entre
escritores y amantes de la literatura y
dedicaremos el programa de cultura de la
semana que viene a las series de bogotá
y de buenos aires
y en el río de janeiro volvieron las
plumas los brillos y la sombra con el
regreso del carnaval mientras las
fiestas callejeras pudieron escaparse en
ocasiones de las prohibiciones las
festividades oficiales fueron canceladas
en 2021 cuando el kobe 19 seguía matando
a cientos de personas al día en brasil y
este año los desfiles en el legendario
sambódromo fueron pospuestos de febrero
a abril debido al aumento de las
infecciones causadas por la variante
omicron la parálisis del mundo de la
cultura estos últimos años da un sabor
especial a la vuelta a los escenarios de
artistas como el ministro de la
cantautora escocesa que mezcla música
pop e influencias soul y gospel regresa
con su cuarto álbum de estudio let's
safe for instance que se estrenará en
mayo el ministro de paso por los
estudios de france 24 en parís para
hablar de la grabación de este disco con
acentos de electro y nos dio a conocer
su nuevo tema family familiar que va más
allá de los lazos biológicos la
escuchamos por eso es importante que
este sea el primer sigue para mí porque
realmente quería hablar de una familia
global este perder por ejemplo esta
conexión con los fans en el sentido de
no ser capaz de estar en el escenario
realmente me hizo pensar que somos una
familia somos una familia musical y no
puedo esperar a volver allí de nuevo y
si esto fue como una afirmación para
toda la nueva era en la que siento que
estoy entrando como ahora que sé quién
soy ahora que mi familia está bien mi
vida personal es agradable me siento
confiada en mí misma creo que ahora
tengo esto resuelto ninguna luz roja
puede detenerme a graduar de kingston
[Música]
pasamos ahora a los estrenos de
videoclips que marcaron esta semana por
su creatividad en museo el
puertorriqueño y el reguetonero
alejandro nos introduce de manera lenta
y melódica de su último proyecto track
volumen 2
siempre está
[Música]
y los dos grandes nombres del rap
francés balde y hogar sano se ofrece en
un vídeo de evidencia para su
colaboración en el tema de una atmósfera
entre apocalíptica de ciencia ficción y
fantasía que nos recuerda a los
escenarios de juego de tronos matrix o
the walking dead
nos despedimos con las notas suaves del
tema emiliana de la artista de música
afro nigerianos y que gracias por su
confianza y cuídense
y es mi total
[Música]
s
en mi alma